[Music]
this is the second round of bin checks
we're in kai poi today
and we are coming through just to have a
look to see if people are putting the
right things in the bins
especially since we did education in the
last two weeks
this is perfect things have improved
pegasus was really good on
monday we had 38 contaminations the
fortnight before but only four
contaminations this round
we had 10 bins not presented but overall
there was an improvement and people even
coming out to ask have we done the right
thing now
and that's really encouraging everything
else isn't too bad it's just like
you really want the place to come off
like the meat tray is great it's nice
and clean but you don't want the plastic
this is a perfect bin because everything
is clean
it's all the lids are off it's
absolutely it's got paper it's
absolutely fabulous
but we're still finding food and general
rubbish and toys
dart boards modems with all the wires
attached vacuum cleaners nothing
surprises us these days
so i think a lot of people are just
using it as an extra rubbish but another
worst of the contaminations that we're
seeing
[Music]
we're going to be sending people that
have had a second contamination this
week
a letter and just advising them you know
this is an opportunity to still get it
right
because if your bin's contaminated again
for the third time
then the next step is that we will have
to remove the bin and that's not
something that we want to do
but we need to make sure that people
that want to recycle
get a chance to actually have that
recycling process
you